what's going on I just finished playing
just cos 3 for a while you did you
played it for a bunch yeah you've played
it all last week you played it during
the weekend I see you're still playing
it you were reviewed it for gamespot.com
as well eight out of ten rico rodriguez
is back and still a bunch of fun it
sounds yeah it's not too different from
one and two if you play both of those
there are like people were asking me if
it's necessary to play both of those I
don't think so it on for the wonderful
backstory yeah there's a rich lore yeah
rich Laura himself isn't it no but there
are callbacks to like returning
characters and obviously Rica himself
yeah I could I put computer bowl games
could not tell you one other characters
and they go again oh I just finished the
game for like 35 hours a night Rico's in
it that's the beauty of their you know
having so much time passed but three
like this and just goes to is it like
2009 you didn't want to say or something
maybe a pretty fun maybe age maybe the
farmer at great games so what's similar
what will fans of the series
experiencing just call three that
they're used to i'm guessing you
liberate a lot of settlements yeah it's
very much still just a sandbox and every
you know every way it's good start you
can fly jets into the statues you can
you know hijacked jets you can fly
helicopters into buildings and then
wingsuit out and tether another
helicopter to the ground and pull it in
Rico can take a fall as well I believe
oh yeah um I fell from about 550 killed
most people it would and then but you a
lot of times you get shot too much
obviously you're gonna die but he still
can take a lot of damage which is good I
appreciate that because I don't really
want to die in this game I want to blow
things up and it's not it's not like
it's actually not as thoughtless as it
looks like Rob and I rob was playing a
lot doing all our video worked for it
and he caught the video review and he
was you know like I was going through
the story missions I think Rob largely
ignored those and just pretty much opted
to experiment with a tether and
everything and he was doing some crazy
[ __ ] that I wouldn't even even thought
of which is the great thing about this
game let's talk about that then for a
second so the obviously we used to him
being able to jump from vehicle to
vehicle that used to be the sort of the
bed and just calls now you can tether
objects together and
to retract them and that you've got my
the minds can be upgraded to have
Rockets put on and stuff like that do
you use that in combat much uh you yeah
the tether definitely I mean when you
first get it you can tether like if an
enemy's shooting at you because in this
game guns are actually like the most
boring way to fight people but you can
tether someone to the ground behind them
and then pull them and or just pull two
guys into each other pull an explosive
barrel into someone so it's really
helpful in the heat of the moment I
think I resorted to guns but the game is
really fun when you can just kind of
plan something out and put mines all
over the base before they know you're
there and then fly out start grenade
launching them from the parachute and
then detonate everything and then watch
people will go flying all over the place
it's also fun to hijack butts yeah
hijack never put the rocket things I
mean you're hijacking in one way or
another yeah so you're claiming it for
your own when you say and you launch
someone his space by wow their butt
cheeks you know if they said that in the
game i'm not sure what apostasy or sore
berating me not know if you buy this
game you stand a chance of winning an
island what it's on the cover of the bar
really purchase this game for a chance
to win an island it's not is it no it
better not be doing a study gonna write
a letter okay sobbing so yeah probably
like some come where and feed you kid in
Montana just wins Ireland solder than
he's in charge doesn't look anything
like this either it's raining the whole
time uh Peter what is it a bad light
just goes one and two came at they were
sort of on the you know that whole xbox
360 open-world game like the dawn of
that sort of that genre really exploding
like we'd had games like GTA but you
know off the back of this and infamous
and crackdown and like we're just so
used to them they're like the open world
is just it's not even a genre it's just
the way games are what do you think it
is a bit just cause 3 which is
essentially a it looks rather like just
cause 2 and 1 and that makes it still so
appealing its people so looking forward
to this like we see in the comments you
see it all over online the forums and
Twitter like people are so looking
forward says what do you think it is a
bit just goes treated this it has this
lasting appeal because back to what Mike
was describing right there are so many
tools that expand your possibilities to
do and experience new things and very
few limitations upon those those tools
and it's you know the fact that you can
create a series of events that chain
together so perfectly and that it works
so well without
any like air of seriousness I mean this
is ridiculous and they have unlocked all
this ridiculousness and that works so
well where so many games take themselves
very seriously and perhaps say we don't
want you to do this or we don't want you
to do that test you could blow up
anything you can blow him anybody you
can make them blow up into each other
like it it's just amazing to me how far
you can go in this game before you've
hit a wall that is like that's not
possible yeah okay yeah it's like
they're lying for what's acceptable or
possible is pretty far yeah and if they
totally upgraded the extent of G's
abilities look at this nonsense I know
look there was there was a Jeep tethered
to that jet that was robbed also right I
believe at one stage Rob I like the
ideas fun yeah tethering a helicopter to
the Grand he picked up a raucous or
sorry he picked up a tank and then
dropped the tank out of the air jumped
out of his plane into the tank and then
drove the tank around the base and then
blew the tank after he was done reattach
the rocket minds previously all right
before everything and then used it to
detonate it yeah let's talk about where
this game falls short I guess which is
sort of you were alluding to the fact
that Rob basically didn't do much of the
campaign stories because he wasn't
really into it in your review as well
you weren't too hot on the campaign yeah
I mean I wasn't expecting a great story
and I don't hold it against them the
story served its purpose do they say
like go blow up these rebel bases and
then they add on like will rebuild
whatever we need to so that's pretty
much just saying Rico there's no such
thing as collateral damage just go do
whatever you want so let's just rebuild
all those people be right and those like
two billion dollar that whole continent
pretty much and that's actually not that
expensive a continent but it's not
continents an island right sucker crazy
they're not giving away a continent on
the box yeah I know that be crazy cuz
then hope it's not you up yeah but yeah
it's it's just what the screw the actual
gameplay of the scripted missions
themselves which are they're not
essential to playing you could avoid
them but in order to you again yeah in
order to unlock certain abilities in
certain vehicles you do right um you'd
still have fun without doing it but
those really were very repetitive there
else they're always there a lot of
escort missions and the AI companions
like obviously we all love escort
missions as it is yeah but no I'm
kidding but the AI companion themselves
are pretty inconsistent they'll
sometimes die right away the checkpoints
will have you they'll reload you at
previous checkpoints after someone just
screwed something up that was clearly
not your wallet all right frustrating
and I guess lastly let's talk about
there's been a bit of a blowback today
on the Internet of edge performance
which always tends to be we can't really
tell if there's a lot of people
experience it or not me and Rob data
gamespot plays earlier today when we got
some framerate hitching on the pc but he
hadn't really optimize the settings for
it what did you play this on and did you
find any sort of graphical stuff it's a
bit of a paradise right right I played
about 30 hours on PC and then I played
another between like two and four on
both xbox one and ps4 consoles are
noticed pcs noticeably better the frame
rate dipped a lot more on consoles it
was nothing that would actually have
affected my score on individual
platforms but it was less of a frequent
issue on PC because pc looks it's a
really good looking game especially over
the water and everything but every once
in a while on all platforms the script
admissions again would not trigger
correctly so you have to like steal his
tank at one point but the boat itself
and it wasn't like a the part of the
script the boat itself just would be
floating away as you're trying to drive
on to it the next time would be fine but
then I want to play it again a ps4 the
same thing happened Wow okay and
assistant bugs yeah and that's that's
like a kind of a bummer because a lot of
the reason I was looking forward to this
aside from the fact that there's another
excuse to play at Just Cause games
because as opposed this is like the ps4
the Xbox one is opposed to the xbox 360
so like the technical less of like
technical limitations was a big draw for
me with this because I was like well
what now what can I do that we have this
much more capability god knows what the
modders are gonna do on pee smells yeah
i'm looking forward to it Just Cause 3
in 2006 he's gonna be super dumb peter
brian like I'm hardly thank you so much
going on talking about that video game
is that the last big release of 2015
then in terms of the review team rainbow
6 siege Scott's working on that yeah and
I think that's the last you know big
yeah the season uh yeah but dude it's
gearing up again in February with an
onslaught of stuff yeah a lot of stuff
push network and this week is crazy yeah
we're also concentrating on 2015 with
our game of your coverage as well yeah
yeah it's gonna be nuts let us know what
you think I've just cause 3 excited to
play it on PC are you gonna pick it up
on console let us know if you think it's
maybe a late contender for those Game of
the Year award
as well maybe creep on in there put your
thoughts in the comment box below